[Music]
please welcome the very funny Hari
Kondabolu great to be here so before we
begin I'd like you all to know that the
theme of my set tonight will be
colonialism which is why I am speaking
only in English I was at a restaurant
recently I was overhearing the
conversation at the table next to me
this man was angry that the waiter was
speaking Chinese it should be noted at
this point we were at a Chinese
restaurant if there's one place where a
waiter should be allowed to speak
Chinese it's at a Chinese restaurant let
a waiter speak Chinese at a Chinese
restaurant you don't think it's
humiliating enough that he has to
pretend sesame chicken is a real Chinese
dish and of course General Tso's chicken
named after that famous general so who
died valiantly fighting to get the seeds
off the chicken it's the same dish why
do we pay more for seeds why don't we
bring our own seeds so it's overhearing
the conversation
further and this man was making a
brilliant argument but why English
should be the national language of this
country
here's his argument When in Rome you do
what the Romans do that was the whole
argument he used a cliche which offended
me because I have really strong opinions
as well but I try to justify them with
facts and logic right I don't use
cliches like I'm pro-choice I have
really strong opinions about why I'm
pro-choice but you don't see me up here
saying I'm pro-choice so don't kind of
chickens before they're hatched
really
that's all I have to offer you that
insensitive cliche When in Rome you do
what the Romans do doesn't even make any
sense
because Rome was an empire you didn't go
to Rome Rome came to you amazing people
using cliches to justify bigotry people
do this all the time
how do people justify homophobia in this
country you know it's not Adam and Steve
it's Adam and Eve look technically that
is true it was Adam and Eve but if you
remember the story it was Adam and Eve
and a talking serpent I feel like the
talking serpent throws the whole account
into question I don't know how true this
is there's a talking snake involved
maybe you shouldn't base your values on
a jungle book type scenario what would
Baloo do I'm a huge sports fan which
usually surprises people cause why would
I root for my natural predator the
athlete
I'm a huge sports fan my favorite sport
of course is chess huge chess head
he's chess I was playing recently I was
losing I had me the king and a pawn left
the other side if I remember had two
rooks two bishops Knight king queen like
four or five pawns I think there was
some weapons from clue on the table
battleship look it wasn't looking good I
turned to my friend I'm like hey man
you're obviously gonna win let's just
sign a peace treaty he wasn't interested
I'm like come on man you already killed
my wife that was messed up yeah we
killed your wife too but somehow one of
your pawns came over to my side turned
back into your wife you're using sorcery
this is more of a checkers audience
but after I lost I was thinking about it
why did I assume I was the king of
course I'm not the king none of us are
the king when we play that game we're
basically all pawns we have a limited
number of options we don't make up the
rules of the game if we die our friends
and family are affected but it doesn't
change the nature of the game the way it
does when the bigger pieces die we're
basically all pawns so the next time I
played chess I played a little
differently I moved all the pawns out of
the way and I moved the King up front
and my friends like what are you stupid
you're gonna lose I'm like no I'm not
gonna lose the King's gonna lose this
isn't my war I don't even know I'm
fighting two moves later we lost but I
felt okay about it because I was playing
with the white pieces thought it was
time we get a black King thank you
[Applause]
the puzzle is in the math section